hey JB smooth back on a set of Kirby  enthusiasm for season 10 oh yeah baby  what's wrong  JB you're actually not working today so  what's what  you're not working today not working  today yeah [ __ ] I'm not look buck I'm  not [ __ ] out of here I'm any good what  if there's a lot about a poppy seed  poppy seeds amazing what are you kidding  what about sesame you like that - I like  the sang it I don't like eating it you  only see yeah we're filming yeah I feel  it too  I'm innocent now you drove in full  costume I did right okay guys look racer  right hey you know the scene yeah  I'm innocent now I'm already here coming  in okay with it reduce Yasim season 10  up in this [ __ ]  [Music]  you